bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale sur france3 avant le journal de
19h nous avons voulu revenir sur les
événements qui secoue dijon depuis ce
week-end quartier des grésillés nous qui
vivons en bourgogne
nous ne nous reconnaissons pas forcément
dans le chaos décrit par certaines
chaînes nationales ou véhiculée par les
réseaux sociaux alors prenons le temps
de nous poser de décrypter avec vous
elle a besoin bonsoir un message fort
d'abord devait être envoyée aujourd'hui
avec le déplacement du secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
oui d'oran et pugnace qui s'est rendue
ce matin au commissariat de dijon alors
visiblement les conditions de sécurité
n'étaient pas assurés pour une rencontre
dans le quartier des grésillés à s'était
pourtant le point d'orgue de cette
visite une délégation a donc été reçue
en préfecture mais pour les habitants
vous allez l'entendre c'est un rendez
vous manqué il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
déception les écoutes ça voudrait dire
quoi prenons une insécurité totale cas
plus une sécurité même pour les
ministres qu'est ce qui se passe à
certains moments on se pose des
questions et on a envie de savoir ce qui
se passe réellement c'est a plus de
police la plus police à plus de
gendarmerie qui viennent il est chez lui
ici bien ici q2 c'est un ministre qui ne
boit des coups on doit discuter voilà
c'est ce qu'on veut on veut parler avec
lui
ce n'est pas normal on sent abandonnée
ce n'est pas normal il aurait dû venir
on est venu là on est sorti aujourd'hui
pour le voir et malheureusement il n'est
pas là ils s'en moquent de nous on
comprend pas pourquoi monsieur le
ministre pourquoi n'êtes vous pas venu
monsieur le ministre pourquoi n'at vous
n'avez vous pas envoyer du renfort
quand j'ai vu ce qui s'était passé
j'avais la rage ils étaient abandonnées
les familles les enfants ça veut dire on
doit sortir armé même les mamans des
enfants du monde et dans trouvons en
direct devant la préfecture de dijon
christophe taris vous avez suivi
christophe ce déplacement de laurent
nunez après les attentes fortes on a
entendu des habitants c'est une
déception peut dire une de plus et j'ai
eu plusieurs sentiments arnaud d'abord
de l'incompréhension et puis très vite
vous l'avez entendu de la colère deux
pas de la part de ses habitants du
quartier des grésillés et avec ce
sentiment une nouvelle fois renforcé
d'abandon qu'il n'allait pas être
entendu il faut savoir qu'il y avait à
peu près une cinquantaine
de personnes dans la rue des hommes des
femmes de tout âge qui espérait être
rassurés avoir des réponses à leurs
questions tout simplement apercevoir le
ministre lors en uni s qui de son côté a
proposé qu'une délégation viennent ici
en préfecture pour discuter avec lui les
députés de la majorité fadila khattabi
didier martin ont fait cette proposition
aux habitants du quartier
cinq personnes sont même montés dans une
voiture pour venir ici avant finalement
de renoncer en chemin laurent nièce a
laissé filtrer qu'il ne pouvait pas
venir physiquement dans le quartier sans
expliquer ses motivations en expliquant
qu'il y reviendrait et qui
s'expliquerait le temps venu christophe
a résolu la préfecture de dijon édition
spéciale sur les tensions à dijon
quartier des grésillés sur france 3 et
pour aller plus loin avec nous elle a
deux invités qui connaissent bien ces
difficultés oui d'abord drissi elle vous
avez dit vous vous habitez le quartier
des grésillés vous êtes président
d'association à vos côtés stéphane
ragonneau vous êtes policier et vous
appartenez au syndicat de police
alliance
driss il vous a dit je me tourne vers
vous vous êtes très impliqué dans ce
quartier comment vous prenez vous le
fait que le ministre ne viennent pas on
le prend comme une insulte
parce que on attendait ben en fait le
problème combat des grésy
on croit que ça appartient à pas qui est
bien en dijon s'est il ya en france et
est une personne qui représente l'état
non
un de ces domaines c'est la sécurité et
il doit répondre envers ses habitants et
le premier qu'on a des grèzes il ya ces
cons après justement toute l'image qu'on
a une mauvaise image des grises il ya
est bien là les brésiliens voulait nouer
le dialogue est malheureusement mais on
voit bien c'est soit le dialogue est
rompu donc on n'a pas le son et on n'a
pas le ministre ou soit on nous envoie
des brigades de crs quand tout est passé
donc c'est bono je me tourne vers vous
un ministre qui vient pas sur le terrain
dans ce quartier ça veut dire qu'on
n'est pas en sécurité aujourd'hui on
grésy alors je ne suis pas le porte
parole de mme isson une aise
moi personnellement il a décidé de pas
venir il doit avoir ses raisons je ne
veux pas m'étendre la salle et pour
quelles raisons non je ne peux pas vous
dire ça vous surprend
ça veut dire quoi il calcule que l'on
n'avait pas les moyens de sécuriser sa
venue je pense qu'on a les moyens de
sécuriser sa venue simplement il faut il
faut bien se dire que vu l'attention qui
a eu ces derniers jours sur dijon
pendant quatre jours et la tension qui a
persiste encore au sein du quartier des
grésillés il est extrêmement difficile
pour un élu de la république de se
déplacer au ca au sein de ce quartier
l'état a confirmé la présence renforcée
de forces de l'ordre ce soir et nuit
précédente et les nuits à venir
également
écoutons justement ce propos les
annonces du secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur
il faut vraiment que les habitants de
dijon qui ont été je le comprends
traumatisés par ces faits mais
franchement je le comprends il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient bien en tête que
je suis venu rappeler ici un message de
fermeté et que nous allons tout mettre
en oeuvre pour confondre les auteurs et
les interpeller
non le le savez à la à dijon la police
est très présente
nous avons des unités qui sont présents
dans les quartiers nous avons des
partenariats avec d'autres acteurs qui
sont très importants dont avec la
commune avec les bailleurs sociaux avec
les transporteurs
il ya un partenariat de sécurité qui se
met en place dans le cadre de la
sécurité du quotidien et donc nous
sommes présents et nous allons démontrer
évidemment de cette présence allait
aussi très fermes quand il le faut j'ai
évidemment décidé de renforcer le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
sur le terrain puisque ce soir il y aura
à dijon 2
unités de forces mobiles qui seront
présentes sur le terrain ça veut dire
prêt de près de 150 fonctionnaires aux
militaires de la gendarmerie plus les
effectifs locaux qui seront présents sur
le terrain pour assurer la sécurisation
et ça c'est fondamental
drissi elle vous a aidé ça va rassurer
les habitants ces moyens supplémentaires
moi je pense qu'en fait il ya déjà eu
des ddd policy fin à toutes mesures
répressives tout ça mais c'est pas la
réponse on chez animateurs en mjc
s'attendait alors à nous ce qu'on attend
aujourd'hui c'est déjà plus de moyens et
les met les moyens c'est pas les moyens
de qu'on attend c'est un moyen
d'éducation et des classes qui ferment
et de la pauvreté il ya des gens qui
sont sans emploi il ya des problèmes
sociaux et ça dénote là qui en fait on
est abandonné en un sens on sent qu'on
est abandonnée et jeu qui me ce qui met
vraiment qui m'agace et les discours des
politiques
il sera en renforçant fait le discours
du front national c'est voilà les
grésillés sans rien faire alors qu'on a
beaucoup de compétences dans nos écoles
il ya des ingénieurs qui sont sortis à
des médecins il ya de tout il ya des
gens qui savent faire les choses de
leurs mains et tout ce qu'on pense des
grésillés juste deux trois personnes
mais alors que la majorité des
brésiliens
c'est des citoyens comme les autres ils
travaillent et y perd hiller zendani ce
qui s'est passé depuis trois jours bien
sûr cette violence des gens ont déjà la
première chose qu'on condamne madame c
pendant trois jours on n'a pas vu un
policier défendre les citoyens dit c'est
toi la crise il alors vous en avez un à
côté de vous justement comment vous
expliquer c'est une question qu'on a
beaucoup entendu depuis trois jours
stéphane ragonneau que la police soit
pas intervenue plus fermement notamment
en empêchant ces deux chaînes d'entrer
dans le quartier des grésillés
vous savez de ces derniers temps c'est
quand la police intervient il fallait
pas intervenir et quant à l'internât pas
il fallait qu'elle intervienne moi ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que vu la
situation le contexte avec les mes
collègues professionnels sur le terrain
ils ont décidé de faire ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est à dire de suivre les
personnes essayer de contrôler au
maximum est de maintenir au minimum les
violences qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit
aujourd'hui s'il y avait eu des morts
qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit cet âge vers
nani tchétchène quand même qu'ils sont
qui font la loi dans ce quartier
pourquoi on n'intervient pas parce que
on avait là quelque chose dit nuit
quelque chose qu'on n'avait jamais vu en
france et d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
dijon fait la une
partout on a vu vraiment une horde
groupe de personnes organisé venir sur
le territoire de dijon au départ au
centre ville peu après dans la
périphérie de dijon pour finir après aux
grésillés personnes organisé armés avec
des armes de guerre convié pas faire le
poids on pouvait pas faire le poids
ou alors on aurait mis simplement une
allumette sur sur quelque chose que tu
es explosif alors moi ce qui me choque
par contre c'est que le avant-hier le
cadre et le cap c'était quadrille à 20h
les tchétchènes sont rentrés à 20h05
je trouve ça quand même bizarre quand
même que pour délit avait des crs et une
personne dont je salue aujourd'hui j'ai
une pensée pour deux personnes qui sont
blessées et par balles de gros quand on
voit la violence on dit est la violence
mais les premiers si les brésiliens on a
deux brésiliens qui sont à l'hôpital l'a
donc deux qui sont en train qui sont
entre la vie et la mort et c'est ça et
je pense qu'il ya des gens d'aujourd'hui
qui ont du sang sur les mains
et malheureusement ce que la réponse
policière quelle réponse aujourd'hui on
entend donc avancer vous l'entendez
stéphane ragonneau non je peux pas
l'entendre je veux pas l'entendre pour
la simple et bonne raison que la police
ne choisit pas les personnes qu'elles
protègent comme elle ne choisit pas ses
délinquants quand on va les images qui
est qui sont diffusées sur facebook par
exemple on va on s'aperçoit très bien
qu'il ya des mouvements foule incroyable
qu'il a fallu attendre un certain temps
pour avoir les moyens nécessaires et
intervenir en feront on est plus
d'hommes effectivement puisqu'on a
appelé des policiers du département
voisin
et dieu sait que nous aussi nous sommes
en manque de moyens puisqu'on a fermé
beaucoup de d'unités spécialisées style
bac qui aurait pu intervenir encore plus
rapidement c'est dommage parce que
l'egypte les gilet jaune y avait les
moyens de sécuriser et est ce que je
suis ce que je regrette par contre c'est
pas cueilli hier donc on savait au bout
de trois jours il est toujours pas de
crs dans le quartier d'habitude tout le
temps et à tout le temps des crs quand
par hasard et les crs sont partis les
crs ont laissé la population
ça veut dire qu'ils sont partis ils ont
attendu de le surlendemain le soir pour
agir j'ai l'impression a fait que c'est
ce qu'ils voulaient en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il a il joue le rôle de
le jeu du front national c'est très bien
que moi je trouve dommage que les
policiers
malheureusement je trouve un pas pour
tous pour certains eh ben il faut il
joue un jeu
dangereux de faire passer du dir est en
fait y'a plus de sécurité en france et
je trouve que c'est dangereux ce jeu là
alors justement sur ce terrain politique
condamnation unanime des violences bien
sûr un appel au calme
marine le pen était à dijon tout à
l'heure pour une déclaration dans un
hôtel près de la gare devant lequel des
opposants ont manifesté
nous retrouvons sur place marie line
baratte effectivement arnaud marine le
pen a organisé une conférence de presse
express dans un hôtel près de la gare de
dijon donc bien loin du quartier des
grésillons où auront lieu ces quatre
nuits et de violence urbaine
mais ces événements lui ont offert une
caisse de résonance parfait pour ses
thèmes favoris à la présidence du
rassemblement national a parlé d'une
france gangréné par l'insécurité et le
communautarisme à ce qu'elle a également
décoché quelques flèches à emmanuel
macron sans jamais le citer laissant
penser qu'elle était déjà dans la course
pour les présidentielles de 2022 je vous
propose de l'écouter par racisme qu
avait pu à juste titre évoqué le
président de la république dans un
moment de lucidité ne portent plus
seulement comme il le croit encore sur
les valeurs de notre pacte républicain
il se manifeste désormais par une
sécession territoriale armée et
judiciaire qui s'affirme sans complexe
cette situation est d'une gravité inouïe
elle dépasse le fait divers et doit
s'envisager pour notre nation comme un
avertissement alors la venue de marine
le pen n'était évidemment pas du goût de
tout le monde un peu plus tôt dans la
journée françois rebsamen le maire de la
ville de dijon avait parlé avait déclaré
qu'elle n'était pas la bienvenue et 100
à 200 manifestants attendent et la
leader du fn devant l'hôtel où se tenait
sa conférence de presse ils ont été
dispersés par les gaz lacrymogènes de la
police mais nous avons pu recueillir
leurs ressentis il parle de récupération
politique
on veut pas qu'elle se rapproche à ce
genre de choses
sur dijon donc on doit lui manifester
notre antipathie je suis c'est parce que
je supporte pas
rien de faire de la récupération 12h15
non
manifestement rien à faire
reste du temps il
elle bien femme un retour
contient de la violence
à dire
nous avons demandé à marine le pen si
elle allait se rendre dans le quartier
des grésillés elle nous a répondu
qu'elle ne pouvait pas faute de temps si
malines bart et en direct de la gare de
dijon pour france 3 bourgogne question
il ya d'autres beaucoup d'associations
dans le quartier comme la vôtre qui font
bouger ce quartier comment vous
expliquer tout ça ça soit gâchée par une
poignée d'individus en fait y'a rien qui
ait gâché en fait parce que nous on
travaille tout le temps même le préfet
dix ans la cuillère et d'un violent
selon centre-ville à des violences moi
je t'ai médiateur transport ya de la
violence tout le temps et c'est surtout
centre-ville cada violence on se
focalise mais nous les activités nouveau
choc fut un membre d'un club de foot je
suis en animation des mjc ont été
ouverts toute la journée il se passe
rien en fait laissé quelques violences
mais là mais la majorité des gens
travaillent ont fait de l'animation on
fait des activités
le problème aujourd'hui au grisy de
cette petite minorité c'est le
communautarisme c'est le trafic de
drogue c'est le chômage c'est quoi le
problème c'est les moyens
comme je vous dis à des classes qui se
ferme il ya des subventions l'état a pas
donné à la municipalité qui nous
accompagnent les moyens de mettre en
place une politique des éducateurs des
enseignements c'est sako visées sur
l'animation et l'enseignement stéphane
ragonneau vous êtes optimiste vous pour
ce soir pour les prochains jours le
calme est revenu
en tout cas nous on est optimiste dans
le sens où on a prévu s'il y avait des
ennuis d'être présent après ans gars si
on n'a pas une boule de cristal
est-ce que ce que on la sent un peu
électriques ou au sein de quartiers du
brésil mais c'est normal vu les
événements qui se sont déroulés pendant
quatre jours mais cependant on a theme
l'effectif assez conséquent
malheureusement qui va pas durer dans le
temps pour se prémunir de toute
éventualité
quand on a discuté tout à l'heure avant
l'émission vous m'avez dit moi j'ai été
surpris surtout par alors par ces
violences mais par les armes lourdes
qu'on n'avait jamais vu comme ça à dijon
tout à fait on a été surpris d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui fait la complexité de
l'intervention des forces de police
c'est le l'armement qui était utilisé
sur le terrain merci beaucoup à tout
évoquer ce dossier le saut grésy depuis
le week-end maintenant merci à vous et
merci à vous de nous rejoindre si vous
avez zappé seulement maintenant sur
france 3 c'est l'heure de votre journal
en bourgogne bien sûr aussi les types
[Musique]
à
dans ce 19 en bourgogne la réponse de
l'état aux violences qui agitent donc
dijon depuis ce week-end des renforts de
policiers dans ses parages laurent du
niaise mais le secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'intérieur ne s'est pas
rendu dans le quartier des grésillés il
a juste rencontré une délégation en
préfecture pas de rencontre avec des
habitants non plus pour marine le pen la
présidente du rassemblement national a
donc pris la parole depuis un hôtel pour
fustiger l'abandon des quartiers
elle parle de guerre civile à l'origine
de ces nuits de violence l'agression
d'un jeune tchétchène nous demanderons
aux commandes des dizaines de
ressortissants ont organisé leur riposte
jusqu'à cette expédition punitive et
plus dans l'actualité de ce mardi
il y aussi les manifestations de
soignants pour demander des
augmentations et des moyens
supplémentaires pour les hôpitaux
près d'un millier de personnes au
centre-ville de dijon plusieurs
centaines aussi dans l'yonne comme à
sens et à auxerre des ministères de la
santé et promet un alignement avec les
autres pays européens
après quatre jours de montée en
puissance de la violence dis-je à dijon
quartier des grésillés secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'intérieur était
donc très attendue par les habitants
il l'a réaffirmé un message de fermeté
aux policiers aux élus mais le rendez
vous sur place n'a pas eu lieu
christophe taris tiffany pfeiffer je
veux aller sur place beaucoup mieux
et encore il ne viendra finalement pas
cela devait être le point d'orgue une
déambulation dans le quartier des
grésillés pour rassurer montré la
présence de l'état
mais laurent nunez a fait faux bond
renforçant la colère et le sentiment
d'abandon des gens du quartier ministre
qu'un peur de venir dans un quartier ça
prouve encore que la population elle
était légitime d'avorteurs tués ces
trois derniers jours
ça voudrait dire quoi qu'on en
insécurité totale qui a plus une
sécurité même pour les ministres
pourquoi ils ont rien fait on aimerait
bien avoir une réponse du préfet de
police est bien qu'au talent elle tend
pourtant l'important dispositif policier
était en place la voirie faisait peau
neuve
pendant que les députés de la majorité
tenté de parlementer
moi je transmets la proposition du
ministre de rencontrer une délégation en
préfecture c'est assez classique comme
méthode souvent le préfet reçoit une
délégation quand il ya une manifestation
souvent les ministres viennent sur place
oui mais il est difficile à aimer liste
de parler un très grand groupe
laurent nunez aura donc écouter en
préfecture où ce matin plus de deux
heures à l'hôtel de police avec les
forces de l'ordre ou encore les élus eux
aussi remonté comme le maire de chéneaux
un sentiment de colère de colère de voir
que les appels répétés réitéré au
gouvernement au ministre de l'intérieur
ne sont ne sont pas entendus et qu'il
faut attendre il faut de tels événements
pour que nous ayons nous y ont peut-être
une réponse reste enfin le message
délivré devant les micros par le
secrétaire d'état le ton se veut ferme
il faut vraiment que les habitants de
dijon qui ont été je le comprends
traumatisés par ces faits mais
franchement je le comprends il faut
vraiment qu'ils aient bien en tête que
je suis venu rappeler ici un message de
fermeté et que nous allons tout mettre
en oeuvre pour confondre les auteurs et
les interpeller
ici en france la justice elle est rendue
par l'état nous sommes dans un état de
droit personne ne peut se faire justice
par lui même enfin il a annoncé
l'arrivée ce soir de deux unités de
force mobile soit près de 150 gendarmes
qui seront présents autant de fois qu'il
le faudra
autre déplacement d'une leaders
politiques et pas davantage de dialogue
marine le pen a choisi de prendre la
parole dans un hôtel près de la gare de
dijon marlene baratet des opposants
étaient également présents en nombre
effectivement arnaud c'est donc ici dans
un hôtel bien loin des grésillés dans le
quartier de la gare que marine le pen a
fait cette visite éclair et surprise
elle a été accueillie effectivement par
100 à 150 manifestants elle a eu un
petit peu de mal à rentrer dans l'hôtel
un peu plus d'une heure de retard mais
elle a profité des événements qui ont eu
lieu au grésy ces quatre derniers jours
pour revenir sur ses thèmes favoris la
guerre civile la barbarie la hausse de
la délinquance en france du
communautarisme
elle a également réclamé effectivement
le moratoire sur l'immigration
et je vous propose de l'écouter sachant
qu'elle a aussi décoché quelques flèches
à emmanuel macron sans jamais le citer
le séparatisme qu'avait pu à juste titre
évoqué le président de la république
dans un moment de lucidité ne portent
plus seulement comme il le croit encore
sur les valeurs de notre pacte
républicain
il se manifeste désormais par une
sécession territoriale armée et
judiciaire qui s'affirme sans complexe
cette situation est d'une gravité inouïe
elle dépasse le fait divers et doit
s'envisager pour notre nation comme un
avertissement alors est la venue de
marine le pen n'était pas du goût de
tout le monde ici à dijon le maire de la
ville françois rebsamen a déclaré un peu
plus tôt dans la journée qu'elle n'était
pas la bienvenue et donc je vous disais
des manifestants à l'attendait devant
l'autel ils ont été dispersés par des
gaz lacrymogènes
venant de la police nous avons quand
même pu recueillir leurs réactions il
parle de récupération politique de la
part de marine le pen veut pas qu'elle
se rapproche à ce genre de choses
sur dijon donc on doit lui manifester
notre antipathie je suis c'est parce que
je supporte pas
rien de faire de la récupération
politique sur le dos
le dijonnais manifestement rien à faire
reste du temps et
elle vient pas mal autour
quand tu y vas violence
à dire
marine le pen n'ira pas dans le quartier
des grésillés elle nous l'a dit elle
manque de temps merci marc barrât depuis
la gare de dijon au moins quatre
interpellations c'est le bilan de la
quatrième nuit de tension ni tension
comme dijon n'en a jamais connu hier des
jeunes du quartier des grésillons sorti
les armes pour défendre leur territoire
par crainte d'une nouvelle offensive des
ressortissants tchétchènes venu en
expédition punitive ce week end
des voitures ont été incendiées à
chenôve
fabienne acosta avec noël duc les
stigmates étaient encore visibles au
petit matin dans ce quartier des
grésillés
le calme n'est revenu que quelques
heures plus tôt après de nombreux
départs de feux et d'actes de vandalisme
sur cette place galilée
les travailleurs ont évacués à temps les
habitants eux sont restés cloîtrés toute
cette bande de jeunes cagoulés avec des
barres de fer les armes et où c'était
après son nombre impressionnant j'ai
jamais vu ça j'ai eu la peur de ma vie
j'ai a tremblé chez moi j'en tremblais
je te ferme à clé hier la tension est
montée en fin d'après midi dans le
quartier des grésillés des dizaines
d'individus armés et cagoulés sont
rassemblés ils veulent en découdre ce
prêt à répondre aux provocations des
tchétchènes par la violence des tirs se
font entendre
le raid est déployé dans la soirée le
soir les tchétchènes et en partie les
versions les jeunes voyous de descartes
et alentour qui sont venus faire
semblant de le rétablir leurs ordres
naoshi qui n'était pas leur république à
il a fallu les faire évacuer par la
police qui l'a été en nombre en nombre
suffisant pour reprendre en bâche au
quartier le phénomène s'est ensuite à la
ville de chenôve pour une autre
démonstration de violence
dix neuf véhicules sont incendiées des
sommes venus pour la plupart des
grésillés cherchaient à créer un autre
point de crispation avec les forces de
l'ordre le calme n'est revenu qu'après
l'intervention des crs
cinq personnes ont été interpellées je
ne sais pas si ce sont des trafics de
drogues en tous les cas une enquête qui
est actuellement menée pour tentative de
meurtre en bande organisée pour
effectivement aussi incitation à la
haine
donc d'essayer crav j'attends les
conclusions effectivement de cette
enquête
selon nos sources le jeune tchétchène de
15 ans à l'origine du règlement de
compte lancé vendredi a été entendu
aujourd'hui à dijon par les enquêteurs
nous vous l'annoncions hier soir l'une
de nos équipes a été agressé par une
bande isolé et leur véhicule a été
sérieusement endommagé choqué nos
collègues n'ont heureusement pas été
blessé une plainte a été déposée
notre travail c'est de rendre compte des
événements sur france 3 nous connaissons
bien lé quartier dijonnais pour les
sillonner toute l'année pour mettre en
valeur les initiatives les projets des
associations
mais pour dire aussi quand ça ne va pas
nous étions donc aujourd'hui au côté
d'habitants des quartiers dits sensibles
quartier des grésillés à dijon mais
aussi le my h9 leur vision des
événements recueillis par anne berger
c'est des choses qu'on voit jamais des
gens tirer comme ça en l'air la fait
surtout mal le sentiment qu'en discutant
un peuple qui sépare le quartier autour
et regarder tout ça qui compte a l'air
fou n'importe quoi ils sont idiots et
brûlé des voitures de leurs propres
quartiers de notre quartier c'est
absurde
par contre le sentiment général c'est
quand même une incompréhension face à
l'inaction des forces de l'ordre samedi
et dimanche quand est ce que la
comédienne s'est baladé dans le quartier
et dont les cds ont pilé et taper sur
des gens au hasard et moi qu'est ce que
je constate c'est plus en plus graves
voyez ça va pas en diminution dit qu'il
ya quelque chose ça monte et c'est plus
en plus graves
alors où c'est pour aller comme ça moi
je pensais pas quand même qu'ils avaient
encore quand j'ai vu tout les indices à
sorde ou six armes et cdg passer des
jeunes des grises y croire jusqu'à ce
que j'ai vu là - mélange dit comme elle
dit c'est pas possible
les crazy sont délaissés moi hier soir
j'ai entendu des explosions dans la nuit
une heure du matin j'ai dit ça y est les
étais obligé que ce qui se passe au
brésil ça se déplace sur la zone 2
de chaunac à mon avis que la même
population et s'est laissé les mêmes
jeunes qui semblent à la rude qui peut y
avoir de plus mauvais sur le ppi était
vrai que moi comme un cartel tels que je
me dis mais jusqu'où on va aller avec ça
à faire attention aussi qu'il ya très
fort en ondes et des enfants dans la rue
je parle des ventes ont mis en bas âge
des femmes et que forcément on a peur et
que on veut absolument pour protéger on
n'en veut plus sortir
je veux la maison moi perso que m'ont
pas vraiment très très content
revenons à l'origine de ces
affrontements s'étaient soutiennent ce
qui semble être un simple différend
entre des habitants du quartier des
grésillés des ressortissants tchétchènes
après l'agression d'un des leurs pour en
savoir plus sur cette communauté
l'analyse d'une universitaire avec
cécile sauser en quelques heures des
files de voitures rapplique de toute la
france près de 150 hommes issus de la
communauté tchétchène pendant plusieurs
heures ce dimanche ils menacent et
occupent le quartier des grésillés à
dijon
d'où vient-il comment se sont ils
mobilisés aussi rapidement dans la
diaspora tchétchène
il ya un levier très puissant c'est le
collectif le village la famille voir le
clan qu'on appelle le type si un membre
de la communauté a commis quelque chose
de mal soit du légal soit un correct
soit contrevenant aux règles l'ensemble
du collectif va se sentir entachée et
qui est un membre du collectif a été
offensé long l'ensemble du collectif du
clan de la famille va se sentir une
responsabilité de réactions de soutien
de solidarité
que sont ils venus dire que venait-il
exprimé au juste on compte environ 150
milles tchétchènes en europe un peu
moins de la moitié se trouve en france
une diaspora nourrit depuis 25 ans par
deux conflits séparatistes avec la
russie
cette société a été laminé par les deux
guerres elle a été très très abîmé et
psychologiquement socialement et donc il
ya quelque chose si sans doute qui se
joue là dans cette espèce de
déménagement la des espèces de deux
coups d'éclat ou de performances
guerrière comme ça en pleine ville avec
aussi la convocation d'éléments
identitaire simple démonstration de
force alors pour dire son appartenance
au peuple tchétchène
mais justement qu'en pense le reste de
la communauté sur les réseaux sociaux et
à des tchétchènes qui désapprouve ce qui
se passe il ya des tchétchènes qui
l'assumé leurs bandes etc en expliquant
qu'il s'agit d'une défense c'est à dire
que nous chrétiens nous vivons en france
2 nous respectons la loi la constitution
l'état de droit et ça mais il faut pas
venir nous chercher
un constat confirmé dimanche soir par
l'un d'entre eux
la loi française elle n'oublie pas de
tirer sur des gens non ce n'est pas là
pour tuer des gens que ça n'aurait pas
pu faire courir à gauche à droite mais
pour défendre nos valeurs on est prêt à
faire ça récemment des scènes similaires
ont été observées à nice à toulouse ou
dans l'aube mais l' enquête ne fait pas
encore de lien entre ces événements et
pour voir nos reportages sur ce sujet
les témoignages des habitants les
réactions également bfc point france 3
point fr sur notre site internet votre
vraie maximum d'informations tout
vérifié confirmé ni rumeurs ni
approximations comme les aime tant les
réseaux sociaux